hey youtubers it's Charlie this week on
legend of korra it was viva la
revolucion and sandworms
in spite of all that there were a lot of
funny moments thanks to Zuko Bolin and
Asami and in case you haven't seen it
core is all digital now meaning they're
not gonna air new episodes on TV anymore
you just have to watch them on their
website or buy them in the Google Play
Store or Amazon really I just recommend
streaming you on the website just
because they're free but if you're
finding me for the first time I do core
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything
there's actually only a couple episodes
left for episode 10 I'm just gonna start
with top five moments and then I'll do
my review careful for spoilers from
episode 10 if you haven't seen it yet
I'll wait just a second okay everybody
ready here we go number five Bolin makes
friends with the Red Lotus I love that
he got two out of three kisses right
based on the way minghua looked away
from Kazan whenever Bolin said there was
an unspoken attraction I think that that
was one of the correct ones even though
I think that was a misdirect and they
wanted us to think that the moustache
and the sister ones were right I like
that whenever Yuri watch that scene it
sounds like bones just talking about
things that are relevant to team Korra
raised by an older sibling that's Bolin
being raised by ma ko and I've spoken
attraction that's obviously McCory the
Red Lotus is like a twisted version of
team Korra or if you want to go way back
a twisted version of team Aang just
because of the shaved head and Airbender
thing I also got the vibe that Kazan was
the Bolin of the Red Lotus but the one
who gets to react everything if you
remember he was the one that got that
funny reaction whenever Zaheer and pie
Lee started making out during their
getaway Bolin's relentless positivity
always makes me feel better it's an
animated show so his emotions are dialed
up to 11 like he's super bipolar but not
spongebob levels of bipolar so it's not
annoying that would actually be a really
cool sub form of energy bending emotion
bending like you could bend someone's
feels overly friendly Bolin was
definitely one of my favorite funny
moments but some alternatives were
Zuko's dragon being lassoed to the
comically small palm tree and the other
earthbender in the cell next to Mako and
Bolin but on to number 14 course ami for
the win
how awesome are the two of them together
this season if they were scooby-doo
Asami would be like Velma and Daphne's
body and Cora would be like Shaggy and
Fred's body and that's not a dig at core
in any way it's just that I love how the
dynamic changes from group to group
depending on who they pair up like
someone gets to be the smart
and the voice of reason and the other
one gets to be the hard charger
obviously that's always gonna be Cora
whatever group she's in core is like a
linebacker fearless and ready to go 24/7
Asami is the one who's done the homework
she knows the flaws and the cabbage Corp
ships which by the way was one of the
best shade throwing jokes on core of
this season let me know if you caught it
the first time you saw it but it's
basically her throwing shade at cabbage
Corp just saying that they really were
like suck the desert scenes were a whole
other story
they really reminded me of last
airbender whenever they went to the
library plus the Giants and fish was a
nice reference to Frank Herbert's dude
if you've never seen any of the versions
of the movie or read the books you
totally should it's some of the best
science fiction you'll ever find I think
the best version everyone agrees is the
David Lynch one to one with Kyle
MacLachlan and sting I think it's on
Netflix right now but number three
diving into the belly of the beast
korrasami
escapes the sand fish maybe I should say
sand whale but I don't know if it just
reference tune you could also compare it
to Pinocchio escaping the whale the
Millennium Falcon escaping the giant
space slug in Empire Strikes Back and
team aang escaping the library before it
sunk into the sand I don't know which
reference point Mike and Brian were
going for specifically but they all
totally work I think it's interesting
how core did not beat the crap out of
everyone whenever the airship crashed
she just apologized for tricking the
guard I think it's really important for
shadowing for how people are going to
perceive her versus - here during the
revolution if she had taken them all
down she'd be no better than say here
dominating the earth Queen plus there's
the opportunity for those people to go
back to the earth Kingdom and tell the
other military people that she was
really nice but I think Ozzy here has to
do is show everyone how aggressive she
can be making the Red Lotus seem like
liberators and anyone else by default
seeming like oppressors that's the
problem with being the avatar you'd
expect the White Lotus to be running
some sort of PR campaign on your behalf
but right now it seems like Korra has to
sway public opinion all by herself the
only other person I can think of the
team core knows that's a master at
spinning things for PR is Varrick I feel
like he's gonna help out in some sort of
ridiculous
silly way either with his magnets or
just by turning public opinion in course
favor with one of his contraptions but
moving on to the ohshit portions of the
episode number two so here air bends the
air out of the earth Queens lungs
just to be clear this was not the sub
form of airbending he was still
airbending air it was just a very
advanced form of airbending because it
requires precision if he hadn't have
been really good at it
he could have killed her whenever he was
talking about darkness he was
referencing the earth Queen passing out
from oxygen deprivation or at least in a
practical sense whenever someone goes
without air in their lungs for more than
a few minutes the oxygen starts
circulating your brain and you pass out
then reflexively your breathing muscles
and your lungs start up again you can go
for about five minutes without air
though before things start to get really
shitty that's the interesting thing
about the human body and it's also how
people tend to drown like you pass out
you go underwater in your body
automatically starts breathing again but
instead of breathing air you suck in a
lot of water and that's how you drown
but my number one WTF moment revolution
in Ba Sing se
watching Kazan pull the wall down was
pretty sweet but technically I don't
think the revolution will actually begin
until everyone loses their and
starts rioting in the streets the wall
the Kazan tore down was just between the
low-income area in the high-income area
so obviously all the people where maca
and Bolin's family live are gonna rush
into the inner city I actually wondered
if Toph and Lin have any family living
in the inner city anymore their family
was as wealthy as the crowd so there
would have had to been a few cousins
floating around so I'm sure they have
some family somewhere in the city really
all Zaheer is trying to do is light the
match what he's hoping is is that
everyone just opens up and revolt in Ba
Sing se and then it spreads to all the
other cities of the earth everyone's
just gonna end up doing his work for him
of tearing all the governments down
which brings up an interesting point
what does he need Korra for if he could
start the revolution all by himself so
remember how I suggested he might try to
use Korra to sway public opinion in his
favor one easy way to do that would be
for Korra to kill him in a very public
way
he's already broadcast to everyone in
the city his intentions to liberate them
so for them he's the good guy if Korra
were to kill him
that would make everyone flip out in
turbo mode that doesn't mean that that's
what he actually wants Korra for I just
think that'd be a very effective way to
accomplish his goal by sacrificing
himself but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite moment and what do you think
that Zaheer wants with Korra even though
the episode felt a lot smaller than the
previous ones I give it a solid a the
animation was God
beautiful and the character beets were
executed flawlessly Bolin's funny
moments showed us that the Red Lotus are
real people they're not crazy villains
like una lock was Bolin metalbending is
pretty clearly gonna be his Mount
Everest to climb in the next three
episodes I think he's gonna do it to as
many Downers as there are each season in
Korra I feel like every character gets
to achieve their victory by the finale
part of the reason I think he talks so
much is just because he's insecure once
he gets over that he'll probably find
the inner peace he needs to metalbend
the out of everything looking at
the Red Lotus Zaheer is the real
question mark we have no idea what he's
up to
I love how Henry Rollins has created
this really ambiguous menacing character
he's the antagonist but not the villain
from his perspective the villains of the
series are the politicians like the
earth Queens so he's really just the
counterbalance to all of them all Korra
has to do to solve all these problems is
neutralized to here pacify all the
citizens of the earth and all the
politicians no big deal I think you
should be no big problem this one like a
million people remember Mike and Bryan
said that the solution to this season
Korra solution will not be based on her
bending ability is not gonna be a
physical fight that's why I think book 3
is so much more interesting the books 1
& 2 it's more of a philosophical journey
than a slap fight in the street let me
know where you think things are gonna
end this season obviously it's all about
change and last season it was all about
the spirit realm and the physical realm
coming closer together
I feel like this season they're kind of
implying that everyone all that people
are gonna have to get closer together
here's a crazy thought what if all the
nations of the world joined together in
a democracy like Republic City a
republic is usually the answer to
feudalism
even if Zaheer hates all government just
something to think about but now time to
name the winners from last week's
giveaway they're actually two so
congratulations to Michelle Phan girl
Lando and Ian Bennett you guys both win
gift cards I'll be reaching out to you
on your channel for details so be sure
and check your inboxes next week is
episode 11 they're just doing one
episode per week now they might end up
posting the last two episodes 12 and 13
together but stay tuned and I'll post an
update in next week's video if that's
gonna be the case I'm a little bit
behind and I have a Doctor Who video to
post tomorrow morning so I probably do a
Q&A so just post any questions you have
in the comments here and I'll try to
answer them but remember I'm also doing
a weekly Doctor Who giveaway so if you
haven't won
for me yet that's just one more weekly
opportunity to win something right now
click here for last week's pour video
and click here to learn all about the
Deadpool movie thank you so much
watching I'll see you guys tight
[Music]